kevin 19 surge testing has begun in
worcestershire after the south african
variant of the coronavirus was detected
in the area becky johnson joins me now
from just outside worcester
in fernhill how's it going becky
yeah well this is the latest area to see
surge testing after it uh
emerged there is a case in this postcode
area
of the south african variant of coven 19
not linked to international travel
and it was only announced last night but
already dozens of people getting tested
if you take a little look you can see
people
queuing down the road here and the the
test site here opened at midday
it's in a a pub car park a mobile
testing unit and this is for people
without symptoms to come
get a test and then obviously anybody
whose test
returns a positive result will be asked
to isolate and then those positive tests
will go off
for further analysis to see if it is
indeed the south african variant and i'm
told that can take
up to two weeks but obviously by then
hopefully people would be isolating
now you'll remember it was on monday of
this week that
the government announced there were 11
cases detected of the south african
variant
not linked to international travel now
they were
in southport warsaw areas of london
hertfordshire surrey and kent and people
in those postcode areas
have been undertaking tests since
earlier in the week and then in the
middle of the week birmingham city
council announced it had two cases not
linked to travel
and some of the areas have already
conducted up to around 10 000 tests so
this is a very
rapid process uh here i'm told in this
area it is just
one case according to a counsellor that
i spoke to and they are hoping to test
around
6 000 people in the wr3 and wr
9 postcode so there will also be
a driving center opening in the coming
days and anyone clinically vulnerable is
being asked to remain at home
because door-to-door testing will be
available so this is what counselor tony
miller
who also actually lives in this area so
we'll have to book a test himself
told me a little bit earlier it is under
control but we want to know and we want
to
continue with the mass testing of
anybody over the age of 18
within this district and surrounding
areas
people obviously get confused and people
panic
and the question is do i need to have
the test if i've had the vaccine
well yes we're still saying if you've
had the vaccine go along for the test
we want to cover every possible corner
and and get this thing killed we need to
get back to some
normality
now the main concern around the south
african variant is that
it is believed to have similar
properties to the the variant that
emerged in kent so it is thought that it
could be
uh more contagious it might possibly
affect people um a little bit more
than than other variants so people could
potentially get sicker and there is also
some concern around um
the efficacy of the vaccine whether the
vaccine may be less effective
look this testing will find ultimately
whether this variant is spreading
within communities in the uk and and
there are
uh some in the scientific community
saying that this is all coming a little
bit too late the south africans
announced they detected this variant uh
towards the end of last year
and borders weren't closed uh for you
know some
some while after that and therefore
there are some scientists who believe
this may well
uh already be spreading in communities
but we will you know
start to find out definitively once the
results of these mass testing
uh regimes taking place in postcodes
across
england come back and then you know
scientists will be able to analyze
exactly where this variant is within
communities
becky in worcestershire thank you